Hello 大家好，欢迎来到共接真家，我是余陆。
我是周易。
今天我们来聊半卡。
对于我们这种很乖的人来说，半卡可能就是人生最大的赌博之一了。
你又赌它，在你用完之前不要跑路，还得赌自己，持续的去用这个卡。
一直对外声称，我说我是一个人生风险偏好很低的人。
我不做大的创业，我也不参与任何的赌博。
甚至我尽量规避自己欠债。
就是我觉得我的人生是一个一直是一个很很低风险的理财基金。
结果我却在半卡之事情上赌了这么多次。
你最近一次浪费的最彻底，半的最冤枉的卡是那一张。
它有一点远了，但是大概是三万块钱。
是小孩的游泳课，它跑掉了。
但是维权也没有用吗？
它是用职业必电人的方式。
从启动半卡那天开始就做好了跑路准备那种类型。
它的套路一般都是会在一个促销的节点给你来一个巨大额的刻包，让你难以抗拒。
你讲怎么怎么划算，怎么怎么新干净了设备，怎么怎么样，很快就跑。
但那个时候它可能已经悄悄的变更了法人成为它毫无名势能力的老母亲啊什么的。
你去过我们办了之后？
去过，就是那个卡是我们一直在用，就小孩用的课，其实是非常的贵的。
嗯,对。
就你会觉得你原来可能大几百，然后变成一两百的那个卡，你真的很难去就忍住说我不办，我就要七八百一节课来上课。
那我还好，因为我今年就以前浪费的不算，但二零二六年迄今为止我只浪费了一张卡是一千二百块钱。
就是十二节课的太几课，这个课我真的觉得就是人性的展示，我连那个课单的群都不好意思加。
就我第一堂课就迟到了，然后我就没有出发，我现在回忆那天晚上，我是可以出门打个车去赶那个课的，比如我可能迟到了十五分钟。
但是我一看，哎呀，现在一打车一算，就迟到了就没有去。
然后到第二堂课的时候，我又想起这件事情。
我当时又在那，而且当时没有迟到，时间是非常早的，我就觉得算了，第一节课也没去。
我这节课去是不是就赶不上了，我是不是服装也没准备好，他们上内容我也没准备好，我就没有去。
然后从第三节课开始，我就自然而然再也没有去过。
那这个不能顺眼到下一期吗？它不是那种滚动开班？
不是不是，就是一年才开一次班的。
我都想到，听到这里会有什么留言了，不能去公园找大爷学吗？
为什么要报班？你根本就不想学。
我想的，其实我在北京学过，而且在北京白云冠那里，我是学完了的。
就是因为我一直健身，健身的呼吸法和太极的很多的呼吸方法是不一样的。
以及健身的那个起手式啊，那些动作和太极有很大的差别。
然后太极讲什么，沉尖坠肘，然后讲那个呼吸吐那的时候，
我觉得能跟我健身的时候有很多的不同的身体的感觉。
所以我一直真的对太极很有兴趣。
当时在白云冠上完那个体验班中，我就一直想再学。
我真去明年还是认认真真地把这个太极的初级班学完吧。
我一直对自己，觉得自我感觉自己对自己要求非常高。
但是我一想到这12节课我以前都没去，我就觉得哎呀。
当然这也不只是你唯一一个报了名，但没有去用过的卡吧。
所以当我继承到，当然我也没有用吧。
有那个单车的卡，动感单车的卡，还有唱歌的卡。
还有当时从北京去杭州有二十多节国贸的私交。
在这个过程里面，每一次办卡的时候，我们都有想说，
这次我一定会分两种，一种是消费卡，一种是课程，对吧。
每一次报课的时候，我会觉得这次我一定会把它上完的。
或者说在报课那一瞬间，我就已经想象到了，
上完这十节课，或者二十节课，我会成为一个怎样全新的自己。
对，而且还有一个幻想是，我总觉得我上完这一波的课程，
我就可以自己练习，就像你说去公园找大爷，我自己买点气息，
或者我就自己在家练，我就能成为一个更精进的人，
我以后不用再依赖老师，依赖教练。
我曾经试图想把这种办卡的费用，或者买课的费用，
转移到去B站看免费的视频，发现就是看不会，老师一教就会，
但是看视频就是学不会。
你真的很尊重教育。
对对对，因为上课的时候自己那个集中注意力，
和它毕竟有那个手把手的教码，就是跟看视频的手感完全不一样。
我没有说B站视频不好的意思，
我知道这个世界上有很多很多的人跟我说他们的游泳，
甚至他们的长期的力量训练，他们弹吉他画画都在B站学会，
那我觉得也不只是我尊重教育，
可能确实有天赋方面的原因，就是我确实没有通过看着学会。
我觉得你认真上了课的，比如说你之前学的吉他和羽毛球，
你把这些课认真认真上完了，你确实都有了非常明显的进步，
然后你就真的入门了，这是我能看见的。
但是我不知道的是你有这么多，
完全不知道你报了名，
办了卡付的钱的这种学习的。
这个原因就是因为如果没有取得一阵的进步，也不好意思跟人说。
到现在为止，你觉得不管是课程还是消费型的卡，
你哪个是你真的能长期使用的？
我有一个书法课，我不是从小学了很多年的书法吗？
长大以后就丢掉了吗？
之前几年吧，我找了一个老师，他是美院的出来的老师。
他的教学方法很好，然后他带的学生也不多，
但他倾向于从零基础开始带，
然后这个学生可能最好是能够持续跟他学习，
一年交一个年费，每周固定的去两三次。
但我去了以后，他发现，他说，
我发现你的时间和心思都不完全在这里，
你固定的时间来，你也不现实。
但你确实是想，我看得出来你是想要一个写字的地方。
然后我就跟他办了一个刺卡，就是大概十次的样子。
我需要去写字了，比如说我需要写一些作品，
我就跟老师约时间，我说，那我来突击爆一下佛脚，
大家我就知道我有一个写字的地方可以去，
那老师也帮我，他一边会帮我准备内容，
也会帮我准备这些文坊用品，
文坊用品都非常好，
以及他到那个那天写字的时候，一般是下午，
他就说把手的给我写一个字贴，
然后教我具体的那些字，
那些笔划是需要特别注意的，
基本上它是比我把当天要写的作品写完再走。
大概一次写几个小时，
看进度了，就是两到四、五个小时都不等，
如果特别着急，我可能去了，然后速速的弄完，
两个小时就出来了。
就是你能就是坚持在那里写字写两个小时到四个小时，
其实因为你确实也会写，对吧？
需求所迫，我们是可以需求告密的，
就是你必须得练很久，能见人了，
这个才能，老师才能放我走，我才能放我走。
OK，我曾经有一个油画课，
但是这个罪魁祸首不是我，
它是，它转到我手上的时候已经是第三手了，
就是我的朋友A，
购买了较为昂贵的油画课，
他去了一次之后，
放弃了，转给他朋友B，
朋友B就没去，
他就听说那个油画课每一节课是四个小时，
他就说这个刚给我，要不你去吧，
在北京，我也去了一次，
太难受了，因为你不会画，
然后我就是对着空白纸，
老师当然会教啊，
我们是不同程度的，
几个人一起，有小孩有大人，
然后老师会一个一个的指点，
比如对我来说就是完全不会，
那我就是从起稿开始，
蒙的，对着那个，
我就对着那个画架，拿着那些笔，
老师过来一点一点教我，
四个小时，不能看手机的是，
重点是这四个小时，不能看手机，
因为你的手都在忙呀，
我们可以，我们现在，
比较依赖一个叫以关书法的案，
我们要在上面看那个字的字型，
我应该是去了两次，
对我去了两次，
第一次我只打好那个线条的稿，
第二次开始上颜色，
因为他确实，那八个小时说实话，
挺难受的那个凳子也不是很舒服，
然后大家又确实都，
除了我以外的，
其他的几个学生都非常的专注，
因为他们都程度很高了，
他们已经是有作品，
甚至专门学习这个了，
我作为一个新人在那里，
我就是茫然，
我，我脑子里也没有任何的什么胡思乱想，
我只是想这怎么办呀，
这四个小时什么时候结束，
对，我就是面对这样，
只当是在画一个，
蓝色的色彩，都不能说是画，
我只能说我在调，
我的周围的那个整个的背景的基础的，
深浅的蓝色，我一点都不懂，
就是我确实没有任何的油画基础，
我不知道自己在干什么，
可能对我叫的，
所以基础就不应该跟，
就是有一定基础人放在一个班啊，
老是教不过来的，
对，老是一个是老是教不过来，
另一个就是他这样子教我，
我确实学不会，
我可能要学的真的得从，
美术的最基础开始，
据我所了解，
那个课在我这里就流产了，
也没有人去过，
没有接到继承者，
对对对，没有接到继承者，
然后其实那个老师，
他本身是非常有性格的画家老师，
他也培养出来很多的学生，
我了解到就是有很多的小孩，
在他们真的是从几岁学到后面，
考试啊，
硬试的时候取得很好的成绩，
但是对于成绩人来说，
完全零基础确实挺难的，
但那个真的是我人生度过最漫长的，
两次四个小时，
但我不是每节课都上的挺好的，
我有一次去临时跟老师约，
我说老师今天想写字，
老师说正好有空你来吧，
写了两个字，
我们俩一人写了一个字，
老师说我感觉你今天状态不太对，
我的状态也不太对，
我们喝点茶吧，
我们那天...
是只有你一个学生吗？
对，那天...
那确实好很多，
哪怕只是跟老师好好聊聊天，
我觉得都能舒服一点，
但是你看我现在就是游泳课，
我在学自由游泳，
然后羽毛球课已经打了，
从1月1号到现在就打了八个月，
几乎是每周一次，
这种课我就完全不担心自己不会去上，
因为第一是动力非常的足，
我那羽毛球课开车要一个小时的距离，
回家要一个小时距离，
而且是要在周末的早上早起，
我都能坚持下来，
纯粹就是因为真的爱打，
而且每一个礼拜都能觉得自己比上个礼拜打得好一点点，
就那么一点点，
然后又消耗很大，
我现在想想，
羽毛球可能是我真的动力最大的，
现在你想有什么事情呢，
我们周末没有工作，一大早起来，
开一个小时车跑到郊区去学一个东西，
你说这个课的时候你的表情都不一样，
对，就是真的非常非常喜欢，
然后每一次打完就是那种具有成就感，
好像有点跑偏了，
我们在说，
这好像是在说，
我们会学习的事情付费，
但其实还有很多，
其他的，
对，我们是从买客聊起，
我这个持续，
我觉得还比较愿意持续去充值去付费的，
一个是我们家附近那家，
就大家都吃过那个，
南城之光天秤店的充值卡，
因为他们家没有什么优惠，
但就是你如果充300，
他会送30，
充1000,
送个120,
如果他电信，
或者大醋的话，
充1000送300,。
因为我知道这家店不会跑，
你怎么知道，
他的订单是非常的稳定，
不仅仅是面向普通的消费者，
小时候他也有2B的订单，
大家都已经问我，
是不是那家店的股东了，
而且我会持续的，
就是需要消费，
那充卡，
用他这个充值的优惠，
是最合适的，
还有一个呢，
是我们家附近楼下的一个理发店，
他的价格非常的深，
他面向的是社区里的老人，
他们家是60岁以上的老人，
如果只减不起，
就是15块钱，
做社区生意，
所以我一般如果充1280，
我能用一年，
就怎么用也用不完，
而且有的时候觉得他平常做社区生意，
做得很实在，
实在跑了就跑了吧，
这个是这两个，
你真的太人妹心善了，
你刚刚说这两个店，
我心里想就是，
他们不可能都没有任何跑路的风险，
比如说，
甜品店他有可能会经历一个周期，
然后下滑生意，
但是你未必敢知道，
他用的很快，
我动不动，
我那个鱼额就用完了，
因为经常会，
比如说，
我们下期不是会聊到宋女子吗？
对,
见到朋友，
一般我们俩都会带点东西去，
我有的时候想不到带什么，
带去他们家，
另两个招牌的店，
那用的快确实，
而且用的快加，
起冲金额比较低，
这个风险就会小很多，
我到上海之后，
完全没有这样的店，
就是一个是，
首先上海确实他整个，
你比如说，
洗头发，
剪头发，
做美甲按摩，
这一类的店，
都非常的贵，
他办卡，
也还是很贵，
而且办卡以后，
会越来越贵，
对，办卡越来越贵，
然后我唯一现在就是，
其他的因为都是彩雷，
都会放在彩雷那篇说，
唯一现在常庆的事，
就我们家对面有一个，
泰式按摩，
他也没有什么优惠，
他就是冲两千块的卡，
成为他的会员，
成为之后，
他每一周有一次买一正一，
然后我就跟我老公两个人去，
就相当于我们那一次，
去按摩是五折，
他这个卡也没有有效期，
同时我办的时候，
这家店，
就已经开了十几年了，
然后我就想，
因为他按一次，
消费一次，
就四五百嘛，
那我去一次，
其实基本上，
去几次就用完了，
但你看我这么说，
我冲这两千块钱，
到现在几个吃了两次，
我本身还是在赌，
一个是赌自己，
会平凡地去，
按照我们想象中的，
那个理想的自己，
对,
想去生活，
另外一个就是，
赌他不会跑，
或者说他跑路的这个风险，
我是可以接受的，
他们也告诉我，
他说很多的会员，
都是像你这样，
只有周二来，
因为周二会员，
日日买一正一嘛，
就是,
他允许两种方式，
一种是你周二来消费了，
我送一张体验券给你，
你下次来用，
另一种就是，
你周二带一个朋友来，
你们两个人都消费了，
只算一个人的费用，
但是就是，
我自己好像，
几步路，
我就是没有动力去按摩，
虽然他也按得很好，
但是你在运动上，
真的很有动力，
你把两百多节，
超级新兴的课，
居然也用完了，
我真的很佩服，
对，我超级新兴，
而且,
你叫可怕的，
超级新兴发年报，
它里面显示，
我几乎课都在，
八点以前上的，
是早上八点以前，
我有很多的，
七点和八点的，
运动,
就私教课，
一年差不多是，
九十到一百节，
就是我个人上，
就是平均每周，
就是两节，
甚至三节，
而且都是早上，
我就是，
非常大早的起来，
而且我去超级新兴，
如果去上私教课，
是不做任何教统工具的，
我就走路去，
我还是一个离家，
挺远的，
就是走三公里去，
上一个小时私教，
再走三公里回家，
这是我，
连续两年的常态，
所以结果是，
你成了一个，
非常有，
自由量的女人，
就你这个消费体验，
其实是让我觉得，
这是很多时候，
我们办卡的时候，
打不到的结果，
我们经常在办卡的时候，
会想象自己，
上完这两百节课，
是什么样？
对，理想状态，
对,
但是你真的上完了？
也是因为我一开始，
启动的时候，
也是因为我买了个，
剧量的课包，
它是超级新兴电信的时候，
可以平常，
就是四五百的私教，
当时我，
就是海量，
购入私教包的时候，
就两百七十五，
我就觉得，
在上海市中心，
以两百七十五的价格，
买私教，
这不是赚分了吗？
就跟每一次，
办卡的时候，
一样的想法，
就去赚分了吗？
对,
才两百多，
我就觉得，
真的哪怕，
二三线程是私教，
也不可能这么便宜了，
我就想，
我就一把，
卖一下，
确实就，
就上完了，
就还好，
它没跑，
对,
超级新也没跑，
同时,
我也确实全上完了，
反正就是在，
每一次，
买客或者办卡的时候，
我觉得，
非常的爽，
然后,
会觉得自己赚到了，
然后会跟很多人说，
但是这个消费，
就帮我确定了那一刻，
至少,
虽然不能确定，
我能做到什么，
但至少确定了，
我向往什么，
比如我向往，
经常出去美容，
经常出去弄头发，
经常去做指甲，
经常去按摩，
反正就达到一种幻想吧，
身份上的幻想，
你有幻想过什么，
特别想，
想成为了自己吗？
通过消费，
因为,
每次来北京出差，
我看到，
我散落在北京的，
图大体课，
其实我已经冲的是，
尽量最小的客包，
我知道，
我肯定，
无法承担，
更长远的承诺，
嗯,
好像一个渣男，
但即使如此，
我也用不完，
就你这样，
来出差，
帮我把这些客群，
都上完，
我心里面，
真的是，
一个好大的石头，
卸下来了，
就不仅仅是，
感觉自己的消费，
没有白费，
另外也感觉，
这些承诺，
在我心头的，
这些压力，
纽约了，
对对对，
哎,
我也是这样，
一旦有朋友，
说,
用我的卡去消费，
我,
那个感觉，
好好啊，
就是,
那种感觉，
我都觉得，
他在帮我，
就是,
你不要给我钱，
你就去洗头，
你就去吧，
因为我就觉得，
我不能白白，
让这个商家，
给我坑在这，
把他用回来，
我才是赚到，
因为我知道，
那个也，
已经很难退了，
退还会损失很多，
用了就是赚了，
哦对,
这就是我的办卡心理，
从一开始，
办了就是赚了，
到后来，
就是用了就是赚了，
但往往，
商家心理想，
一个好优秀的韭菜，
对,
哎,
我怎么会这么安慰自己，
我总,
总是希望自己是，
赚了的，
那你,
书法办，
你是坚持上的，
有什么改变了你的卡吗，
就是对身体，
学习状态这些，
就这些一直办了，
但没有去用的卡，
让我认识到自己，
真的不是一个，
爱运动的人，
我真的已经发誓，
我再也不会办了，
我现在是一个，
非常倾向，
顺时性消费的，
屁人,
我是个屁人，
决定拒绝，
商家所有，
在价格上面，
玩的任何套路，
我就认了，
我知道，
就是办卡，
他会跟你说，
他把比如说，
600块的价格，
给你打到100块，
你只上一节课，
你就是600块，
但如果你打一个课包，
那你的单价可能是150块，
这种价差，
会让你感觉到赚了，
但是我知道，
我只会去上一节课，
那我其实，
整个付出区的价格，
就是1500块，
1500块和原价，
这个600块钱比，
我愿意选600，
但是,
如果你只去一节课的话，
你只需要在，
商家的，
这些点评，
或者美团页面，
还你的体验课，
就好了，
但是,
你能清晰的，
完全知道，
自己只会去一节，
我觉得这个很厉害，
我到现在，
都还有一点不清醒，
通过就是，
办很多的卡呢，
让我意识到一件事情，
就是,
我确实在美术上，
没有天赋，
穿搭,
化妆,
化化,
我觉得，
所有的这一切，
都需要美，
美术的基础，
我在这些事情上，
采得,
可能是比较多的，
就是,
做美甲，
然后化妆，
还有就是，
一些服装店的卡，
我，我用完这，
我发现，
自己其实是，
没有能力去，
学会,
并且,
成为一个，
自己会化妆，
自己会穿搭，
得人的，
有没有这种可能，
就是,
上了那么长的课，
我们在化妆店里面，
经常会见到那种，
十次课，
五次课，
就是告诉你说，
你上完了这些课，
以后,
你就可以，
成为一个，
怎么样的人，
你就起码，
可以学会，
比较精致的，
日常妆，
或者怎么样，
我去上过一个，
独立的化妆师的，
私教课，
他就说，
你就是要，
一节课，
我一节课，
教会你，
化基础的妆，
然后你回去，
如果你需要用的话，
你就会持续的用，
你用到觉得，
你不够了，
或者你忘记了，
你再来找我一次，
他说,
我不给你卖这种，
十次课，
五次课，
但是现在人，
没有那么多课，
我也上过你这种，
是一个，
那个课还真的，
蛮贵的，
四千一节，
我的课三百，
我给你讲，
他是这样，
他是一个大师，
我是好不容易，
敦到他来北京，
提前预约，
交定经，
然后他在课的时间，
很长,
好几个小时，
从分析，
我的肤质，
全程都有试评，
从我的，
把头发弄起来，
就帮我全部的化妆，
然后又卸掉，
卸掉之后，
让我,
就是第二步，
就让我自己，
他知道我一点点话吗？
回家之后，
我甚至，
根据这个视频，
那个没有AI的年代，
我一点一点看视频，
自己做了一个，
步骤的脑涂，
每一步的注意事下，
色彩的分析，
产品的选择，
然后我就不会了，
我就回家视频，
放在这儿，
脑涂放在这儿，
产品放在这儿，
就那个手就是不会了，
我就觉得，
这件事情，
确实真的有天赋之分，
我最近发现一个，
可以单次购买的，
非常好的东西，
叫毛鸽屏线下化妆，
99单次,
我就打算，
以后有化妆需求的时候，
就去毛鸽屏的专柜，
然后用一次这个，
单次的化妆服务，
你不学了？
我不学，
我真学不会，
你想学，
我们再把那个课，
找出来再学一次，
那也是一次完成的体验吧？
对，就是不会，
就像你意识到自己买了，
搬了卡着去一次一样，
我就意识到美术上，
我就是没有天赋，
不能死科，
我不知道现在00后，
会怎么样，
就是我感觉，
我们这些经验，
或者是教训吧，
是很多年，
真金白银，
付出来的教训，
但是不是，
天生有一群人，
他就会不上这些档，
或者说他就是会，
很自律，
就知道自己是，
什么样的需求，
去付出什么样的消费，
比如说，
我们都没说了，
因为离我们太久远了，
我们刚开始工作的时候，
谁还没在健身房，
办过几个，
从来没去过的卡呢？
因为健身房，
现在想明白，
他赚的生意，
就是赌，
所有办了卡的人，
这里面可能有七八成，
是不会来的，
因为他的容量，
就接待不了那么多会员，
而他也知道，
在人性里面，
大家就是不会去健身房健身的，
当然这是上一代，
健身房的逻辑，
对对对，
这是不卖课，
咱们现在就讲到，
纯销费行的办卡，
跑了一下，
就是健身房的数据，
说健身房的物理容量，
假设是两百人次，
那他至少要卖的会员卡，
是两千到三千，
那么这里面，
只要有一成的人来，
他的容量就是饱和的，
但是你什么时候，
看到健身房饱和过，
也就是说，
其实连一成的人，
都没有去，
就是他的商业模式就要求，
他卖他容量十倍以上的卡，
他才能活下来，
因为健身房的，
场地和设施是极其昂贵的，
所以他就是一个预付制，
加所有的人，
会系统性的高估自己，
等于这个行业的利润，
尤其是，
你看健身房的话，
说这么多年，
其实是没有更新的，
活动马上就要结束了，
越长时间的卡越便宜，
对吧,
给你造成一种幻觉，
你只要天天去健身，
你就会成为一个更好的自己，
但是健身房，
现在应该很难办法，
我觉得应该是大家都，
至少像咱们这样，
都意识到自己，
不会去健身房吧，
就像乐客超级新兴这样的，
模式推广开来，
然后,
大家好像没有那么容易上当，
另外监管也变得规范，
像我开头说的那个小孩，
游泳客那个事，
他应该是不能，
再出现了，
按照相关的规定来说，
他应该要打到一个。
监管账户里面，
你跑不掉，
你从概率上算，
就是健身房不跑路，
同时要加上自己坚持去，
因为这个不是客，
他就是你去那，
靠自己的动力去运动，
这两个不确定性叠加，
他不确定性就狂大呀，
对吧,
就是健身房这个模式，
他就半年卡的健身房的模式，
他就根本就不应该跑得通呀，
健身房的商业模式，
和很多的，
理发店的商业模式，
其实也是一样的，
就是不停的推，
预付卡嘛，
就用新的销售，
来养这个已有的成本，
就理发这个事情，
还不太一样，
就是你认准了一个理发师，
你可能就一直在他那儿，
你不需要付出太多的，
沟通成本，
我有一张卡，
可能用了很多年，
就每当那个卡，
还是那么，
一点点钱，
我知道不足以付，
我下次理发的费用的时候，
我就会很紧张，
因为我知道，
我去,
我就是一个，
即将挨载的高扬，
就理发师就会说，
就是要这一行，
动执一里，
一方面，
我要,
就是你今天的那个，
不够了，
那你如果按照
正常的费用扣的话，
你不还算，
你再充一点，
另外呢，
我们也关系这么好了，
你支持我一下，
支持我的业绩，
嗯,
我就非常的紧张，
所以其实你是，
明知去了，
就会被办卡，
但还是会办，
但后来我学乖了，
后来我就，
像你一样，
就请朋友，
把我那个卡耗完，
就理发师，
千千万，
我全北京，
我还找不到一个更，
对吧,
因为,
就是你看，
这一类的，
这一类的卡，
就是洗头发，
做头发，
做指甲，
做按摩，
做美容，
还化妆，
这一类的卡，
我们也办的非常多，
原因也是，
因为这个东西，
它甚至不能像运动一样，
自己自律就行，
它就得要专业的人才能做，
我需要这个，
来自专业人士的服务，
而这真的也是，
办卡的重灾区，
你就没有遇到过，
这样的门店，
它是不以卖卡为生的，
我现在还真的没有找到，
就是以前我在北京，
有那种独立理发师，
但因为它单次收费，
就比较贵了，
在那个时候，
它大概就是，
五百六百一次，
剪头发，
它只有一个人，
它只做熟客生意，
所以它不办，
按方成规模的，
连锁的，
它的生意模型，
就是,
我用这个办卡来的，
所以我现在变成一个，
损失性消费的人，
就咱们也不是，
服美艺的人，
我们其实就是一个，
基本的一个，
把自己保持体面，
就好的体验，
那我们就找那种，
非常标准的，
比如说，
我做指甲，
我不会做，
非常复杂的款式，
那我其实，
就不需要一个，
非常熟悉的，
没家店，
我任意挑一家，
当场团购，
对，评价还不错的店，
一般来说，
很，早几年吧，
那些团购上面，
还是，还会，
比如说，
团购价是这个色彩，
里面没有什么能看的，
然后再拿出，
另外一个，
非常精致的，
那个装修的，
很漂亮那个色卡，
告诉你，
这个是我们办卡的，
或者说，
一个更贵的，
你单次付，
可能它可能三四百，
五六百，
我现在不，
我就从那个，
团购的色卡里面，
挑,
我们就排除，
那个色卡，
本身的那个装修，
你就只看颜色，
因为我只需要，
最基础的，
对对对，
我不需要那些，
我也是，
我要说两个，
就是我自己办的卡，
一个是洗头的卡，
这个我可以公开，
它的名字，
就是洗个头发，
我在洗个头发，
应该现在，
还有,
八百多的鱼额，
这个事情呢，
就是它没有跑路，
它的店还是那么多，
但它把，
它大部分的店，
都转成加盟，
而新加盟的店，
是单独的业主，
所以它不支持，
像我这种，
老客户，
早年办的卡，
但那个鱼额，
它是没有过期的，
这么一说嘛，
它就是现金在那里，
我就得去非常远的地方，
才能洗这个头，
或者我去别的城市，
因为不同的城市，
那个加盟，
和执营店的那个分配，
还不一样，
我才能去消费，
给我提高了很大的门槛，
还有一个就是，
我在上海办的一个，
没家卡，
这个卡是我眼睁睁看着，
从两百多，
可以做完一次，
完整的没家，
到要四五百，
才能做，
而它在大众点评的，
团购,
一直是一百多块，
这就是让我做一个，
它在杀熟，
对,
然后我会，
我会质问它们的，
我这个还是说出，
我说,
为什么你们大众点评，
上卖一百多，
然后我来做一次，
三次,
它说那个只能用一次，
但咱们都知道，
哎，我用完一次，
你帮我团一次，
不就行了嘛，
就有什么好一次，
我再找另一个朋友，
帮我团一次，
我最近，
刚刚把这样卡用完，
用完之后，
就真的就是，
心里那个愤悶，
因为我，
已经存了钱了，
我不能说，
放弃我这个处置，
比如退款，
好像他们有一个，
手续费，
什么的，
所有的退款，
都是让你，
感觉你只能退到，
一点点钱，
让你觉得，
哦，那还是算了，
我不折腾了，
我把它用完，
然后就，
捏着鼻子，
把它用完，
对，我就是捏着鼻子，
最后一次，
在前天，
把这样卡用完，
然后把这个，
公司,
所有的销售，
删光,
把销唇续退出，
从此以后，
我都想这个品牌，
就是离我远远的，
因为它真的太贵了，
我现在想不到，
我觉得，
所有的老客户，
应该都是我这样的心理，
你怎么能，
我越做越贵，
同时,
你在大陆点评上，
卖那么便宜的套餐，
我真的想想，
觉得自己是一套猪，
你知道吗，
你留的模型，
就是这样嘛，
为了,
他们需要，
用这个，
非常便宜的套餐，
让自己在这个，
点评网站上，
排名靠前，
然后有足够的好评量，
让他们，
足够吸引到新的，
会员,
进入到他们这个，
会员池子里面来，
然后圈起来一起宰。
至少我觉得，
在剪头发，
洗头发，
做美甲，
和化妆这些事情，
我应该都只会，
单次消费，
就是,
单次团购，
它能差到哪去呢？
就像你说，
咱们要求也不高，对吧？
但是,
如果从，
就是小生意的，
同业者的角度去看，
他们其实也有，
所谓他们的难处吧，
比如说，
这种引流款，
你必须要交给平台的，
这种,
叫做引流税了，
嗯,
吸引来的顾客，
大部分都是，
无法再次复购的，
无法复购的这些新客户，
它其实就相当于，
它给平台，
凑了热闹，
但它并没有给它的这个生意，
对,
而且可能没有什么利润，
但是,
我作为，
普通的消费者，
就是,
我是你的老客户，
我交付了信任，
我就活该被你，
这样对待吗？
长沙的朋友告诉我，
他们经常只要50块钱，
就会做一套，
非常漂亮美甲，
但在上海，
可能这个价格，
第一上，
这个有人工和那个，
房租的，
差异,
然后再加上上海，
整个服务业，
就是会比全国其他，
所有的城市要贵一点，
我其实是对这个，
一家是有心理的预期的，
但是我发现，
只要你放弃这种，
办卡的模式，
选择每一次都去团购，
我就成为那个，
商家引流过去的新客户，
而不是被圈起来宰的，
老客户，
因为这也是我作为，
消费者，
一个理性的选择嘛，
但是当然了，
这个过程当中，
有一些风险，
就是你作为一个，
不熟悉的店，
你可能会遇到，
不可预期的服务。
除了我们刚刚美甲，
美发这一类，
餐厅茶馆，
也是我们的重灾区，
嘎嘎,
新巴克，
新巴克还好，
这个我们的宿礼那期，
那宿礼，
Underex,。
然后,
还有以前，
我很爱在一些，
就联所的洗餐厅，
也冲一个，
冲值卡，
我有次，
跟你一样，
我打开嘎嘎，
那个,
准备结账的时候，
发现这一鱼 Three，
还有几百块，
我真的是眼前一黑，
还好看没跑是不，
我都不眼前送，
我喜欢就是，
不要让人看见，
因为我觉得这 long，
你们太丢 Season.。
为什么我都
不是一个挖伽的，
消费者，
瓦格斯会有500多块钱这些事情。
我们有的时候会在那见人吗？
那你一次见人我为什么就要充卡呢？
你肯定是被那种买一千充多少送多少的优势。
对呀 我都想不起来我那个冲动了。
探银行也写了极其的卷。
然后新店开的很快。
老店哪怕是像我们刚刚说的瓦格斯和嘎嘎。
非常之大也不代表他没有跑路的风险。
这些店完全没有必要冲任何的。
提前消费的那种处置。
然后换那一点点的优惠。
我觉得有一种情况比如说。
他是比如冲500送50打个比方。
而我那一顿刚好要请别人吃饭要花掉500。
就当下立刻花完的这个处置优惠。
我会选
但我不介意在任何的餐饮连锁冲值。
我遇到的一些就是真的冲非常多了。
他可能是比如说他在某上某。
某上某这些餐厅里面。
他可能一次的冲5万或者冲10万。
冲到我们平常不会去考虑那些数字。
他就是有那么多的商务宴请的学生。
或者说他愿意从中去套利。
他成为了一次性成为了。
这个大额消费的大客户以后。
他有打招呼可以更好地吃。
我知道
因为上海有那个比较贵的那种喜欲。
他也是餐饮很好
他咸鱼就带下订单。
可以有个六七折那些人就是套利的。
他会在他大粗的时候。
冲4万5万
然后就送1万2万。
然后他再把折扣导手。
在咸鱼上开店卖掉。
每一单他大概能挣个一两百块。
我也不用去冲那个4 5万的那个。
我说实话我听到这个经。
我都觉得有点麻
在一个消费场所冲5万块钱。
而且只为了去吃饭和洗澡。
我真的觉得有点夸张。
反正我是不支持这样的消费的。
除非你是咸鱼卖家。
我们已经说了非常多的这个实体消费。
再往下我们是不是可以说一些。
线上的
这其实是更大的共灾区。
就是这个你
你甚至没有什么明明白白的东西。
可以拿在手上吃到嘴里。
我一共持续办了
四年的看理想的会员卡。
他的回馈给我
就是可以听他APP上的节目。
好像还甚至有一些节目不让听。
我现在也不确定了。
对对对
就是可以听节目
然后每一年
有一些书可以买
就做免费的买书的额度。
但因为他书是原价。
所以他给那几百块额度。
也买不了几本书
有线下会员活动可以参加。
你去了吗？
去过一次
然后咖啡馆
上海没有
咖啡馆可以
大概就是他的全部权益了。
你最开始冲看理想的会员。
是因为当时他比较难。
难以维持
对
给他一些支持
就是觉得这个生意很难持久。
但我没有想到他做这么大。
他第一年的时候
我记得是1200。
第二年是1400。
第三年开始
他推出两种级别的卡。
有可能1000左右的和更昂贵的。
大概1600-1800。
我醒目是什么呢？
是醒目是我没有序卡。
我忘了我没有序卡。
然后我是打开APP。
准备继续听我那些没听完的课的时候。
发现我听不了
我在你APP上花了这么大几千。
我听不了了
我才意识到
那个课买下来只要200块。
可能都不到
198吧他定价大概是。
而我在花了好几千之后。
我在看了一想
四年时间一共听了160个小时。
这160个小时买下来。
绝对不会超过400块。
这也是读你不来了模式吗？
读我来我也觉得很不合算的点是。
198我买下这个课。
我永久反复
因为确实我听的大部分。
是那个高校老师
对一本书的经读
那本书我一定是读过的。
然后我要去听那个学校的教授。
大部分跟他课堂上的。
学术方向是一样的。
我要去听他跟我讲历史背景。
尤其是张爱玲的
有好几个老师都有张爱玲的课。
然后我要去听他跟我讲。
然后让我帮助我
跟进一步理解张爱玲。
这个课我觉得是值得。
我付一点费用去听的。
但是我没有想到
我花这么多钱之后。
此时此课的我在看理想。
就是听不了这个课的。
这一课我就彻底行为。
我再为一个很理想。
就是很理想很理想的。
世界买单
而且付出的价格是不便宜的。
到现在我就听不了了。
后来我也没有再买。
因为我发现那些课。
喜马拉雅或者小宇宙。
也能买到对吧？
我可以单次的购买。
这个课我可以永远的听。
后面我就变成了一个。
就是要听具体
某一个老师的课
就买这个老师本身的书。
或者课
我就永远的拥有他。
我不会再为这样的。
昂贵的会员充值
但是我也有朋友
跟我一起买这个
1000多的会员。
买到了建本文库
1万块钱的会员
我就问他就是
为什么会愿意为一个。
这样虚无的线下聚会。
和书的导渡
花这么多钱
他确实是会去的
他不管是线下的活动。
还是每一本书的导渡。
他都会听的
他就觉得
最早的心态是一样的。
一个是支持
就是梁文道
另一个是他觉得
去了和听了
就是赚到
这就是他跟我不同。
我们就在这个
他真的学了
他真的有时间
他也真的是有这个。
更
需求对对对
他有这个
跟老师们当面交流的。
这个需求
同时他也有时间
每一次
因为每个活动
都不同的城市办
我实在是没有办法。
为了就是
把我这个会员权
免疫用尽
而飞到不同的城市。
承担更多的成本
去参加这个
有意义的文化活动。
就这个模式
确实我就彻底的放弃。
还有就是
当时
应该是疫情
刚刚结束的时候
那种脱口秀剧场的卡。
那就纯粹是
你就相当于捐款了。
相当于血迹仇了
是不是
对
我现在想想是这样。
但当时的时候
也觉得很划算
他应该就是
可能几百块
可以看很多次演出。
但是我
我的实际情况
就是一次也没去过。
我纯半卡
纯消费
然后还书店
你记得吧？
那时候水灾
疫情的时候
我们应该为
很多的书店
都存过这样的钱
单相接
当时就觉得
他开不下去了
那个钱
是怎么样
我都忘了
忘了
我其实就是当捐款了。
那一笔
单相接的
那个会员
应该就是当捐了
他应该是
可以买书的
我不知道
因为我也没有
去看那个条款
这类就对我们来说。
其实是纯情绪消费了。
我还要说一类
就是
日常的就是
电子订阅的消费
相当于你买
是吧？
Kindle
这是我买过的
一个也没咋用的会员。
虽然他已经不在了。
我反而要说的是什么？
像美图
美图秀秀
华欧相机
这个有用
还有一些工具类的。
简硬
对
还有清理照片
我有的时候
最好用的
他需要一个年费
那我就花了一个
永久的费
我把它买了
还有一些朋友提名的。
One Password。
One Password也是永久的。
对
然后我想想
那个训计
对
你可能不做力量训练。
那个是
他其实还好
他就是58一年
然后88终生
然后
有很多的这种
虚拟的app
他就是
接受一个非常具体的需求。
你推荐给我那个
清断石的app
他也有永久费
我买了
我是因为买了
才推荐
给人的
对不起
我
我真的很爱
就是
支持这样的小的创业。
我觉得这个我们
应该单独了
这好像不在我们今天。
这种就是那种
支持型
捐款型
根据自己实际的需求。
来买
因为我们两个
是属于那种
比较容易冲动
被别人的
比较感性的故事
打动
我有时候看到别人创业。
看到别人
做有创意的事情
我就会忍不住
想要支持一把
然后这个过程中
就会
也不能叫浪费
至少我觉得
我对他的支持
他收到了这个
是有用的
这个时候你
心里也爽一下了
对
因为我觉得
是我本人的身份
立场
我在这个世界上
我支持什么样的人。
以及
我是一个文艺青年。
这件事情
我不要说
但确实真的
很多很多的消费
都是基于
我觉得对方是文艺青年。
他的消费者是文艺青年。
而我是他们当中的一员。
我要为我的身份
做一笔券款
但现在我们可能
越来越少
不会把消费放到这里了。
我们越来越
认清了自己
其实真的不需要这些。
这些钱没有必要花出去。
尤其是在
实体的
商业的办卡上面
对
我们很多时候
除了我刚刚说的
为身份券款
还有就是为焦虑
美容和健身和学习。
都是焦虑的一种
我觉得我很焦虑
我什么都不会
所以我去办一张卡。
来对冲我此时此刻的焦虑。
我认为我办了卡
我的焦虑就缓解了。
但其实它是真金白银。
那钱不都是
咱辛苦工作赚的吗？
还好
现在你刚刚也说了。
现在其实法律
已经在逐步完善和健全。
不管是消费者
全营保护法
还是消保法的
那个实施条例
和最高司法解释
在24 25
到26年
这种御付卡
充值卡
会员卡
都有了相应的条款。
我们这个
可以写到修诺茨
因为比较长
我们把这几条
相应的条款
写到修诺茨
大家根据这些条款。
然后该维权维权
该退款退款
然后以及以后
在办卡支的时候
也问清楚
我是不是可以退款。
我能退多少
我退款的条件是什么样。
我最近一次办的卡。
就是那个普拉提卡。
这个店
它非常的就是
就是合理
它就是告诉我在有效期内。
就是可以把你没有消费的课时。
全部推给你
如数退价
对如数退价
不是什么折扣
不是不是
超级星星也是
如数退课包的费用。
我觉得这一点是
我愿意为它再信任一次的原因。
就是相对小一点
然后职业跑路人的事情。
我们已经听了很多了。
这个我希望
这种人应该都能被抓起来吧？
不会的
他们有非常成熟的套路。
我那个勇款
那个勇管跑路之后。
大家不都被拉到
一个维权群里面吗？
我们之首项剩下的。
或多或少
大多则几万
小则几千的这些
给我发的一个
巨价XR文档是
全城非常多家的
这种幼儿的培训机构。
各种本类
什么跳舞 游泳 体能。
什么国学
什么书画
这种
就是说你的这个鱼额。
可以折成多少次这个。
多少次那个
你可以选择
你可以组合
但实际上
你就相当于
被这些职业必电人。
又卖了一遍
你变成了一个
他们每个店都用户包。
就像我们投放的时候。
选的用户包一样
变成一个
所以那次我就选择。
我跟这些全部都
划清切一些
我认栽了
我不跟这些
有任何的来往
我去年有一个朋友。
就在
永安里附近
一个很大的
开了很久的一个建设房。
大家都知道的一个建设房。
跑路维权停开了
也胜诉了
但是钱追不回来
对
这个我倒是
已经有警觉了
来 说回来
我本来是要分享一个最近。
虽然是很小额度的维权。
但是确实是
维权成功了
我是在上一家电影院充600块。
我还剩100多鱼额的时候。
想买几张票去看
因为现在电影票很贵。
然后我那100多。
就买不起多张的电影票了。
我就打电话问他们。
我说我现在怎么办。
他说你只能继续充600。
我能比如说
几个选择
我能把钱推回来吗？
或者是我只补
几十块插额
你让我把这几张票买了。
行不行
他都不支持
他说你唯一的选择。
就是继续往我们这充。
我就被这句话气到了。
因为他居然
只有一个固定的充值额度。
我当时
哎 你知道我
那我也用不完吗？
对 你知道我这个韭菜。
你知道我想法什么？
我说你让我充100呢？
我当时想的时候
亏少一点
就是我充100页写。
我就只剩几十
这样买完票
我甚至已经卑微到这种程度。
他说也不行
你就得充600
我说可是你们的600。
是不可能
完完整整买完电影票的。
那就相当于就像你一样。
每次娱乐不够了
我还得再往里充600。
我就因为这个态度气到了。
就打了12315。
然后12315让我去小程序。
填一个资料
我填完资料之后
他们很快就联系了。
我说他们已经去
跟商家沟通过了
你去退
这个里面是175。
就175
全额退给你
没有折扣
没有手续费
当然了
这个当意不是很公平。
因为我办卡只需要在小程序办。
但是我退款
我需要去到他们办公室。
我要跟他们工作人员交涉。
我就记得那天我去的时候。
他们工作人员看我的脸色。
有多难看
他们早早的准备了一个信封。
里面是175块钱现金。
然后给了我三张表。
让我签
我非常爽快签
整个维权的过程
发了小红书之后
我才知道
原来有这么多的人。
我管他们都叫600块韭菜。
都是像我一样
充了600
又充600
然后发现永远用不完。
这么多的说话者
到现在那个机制都没有改吗？
对 他没有改
然后那些说话者
给我在小红书上发私信。
我就告诉他们打电话。
或者去小程序填资料。
我说稳退
而且退的方式
就是去电源领现金就行了。
我现在已经帮助了。
不差10个人了
他赌的是
维权的人
比充值的人要少很多。
因为他是一个大的。
就是连锁电源
他一定有非常庞大的。
充值的会员
会员系统的成本更高。
还没有动力去做这个事。
也不是
因为会员技术非常大。
而退款的人数
我觉得应该一年没有几个。
让我们就太多联合起来。
既然都一直有人去维权。
一直要找你退款了。
你居然不改
而且
那就一定是因为
那个背后的成本
他算过吗？
还是有很多的人
会一直600600的充。
再加上现在看电影。
又是一个如此高评的。
高价格的消费
看电影变得越来越贵。
那你单独买电影票。
和你充了卡之后
确实有一个
比如单独买
可能要八九十一张。
那充了卡是五十
确实是要便宜不少。
大家还是会愿意充值买。
我其实不太想用
呼吁大家不要半卡。
来结束我们这个
今天这一期
我是希望大家
会
像我们今天其实
也反思了很多
对
商家为什么要半卡。
我们为什么会
因为什么原因去半卡。
这两方的思维模型。
大家可以多想一想。
或许你就可以
更清楚的知道
我是否需要这张卡。
以及这张卡能不能办。
我也不能呼吁
不要半卡
因为我自己
也还是未来
我觉得我很难避免。
成为一个
半卡的人
但是我觉得有意识。
就是我办的时候
要清晰的知道
就像你说的
我知道自己只会去一次。
我知道自己
完全没有美术天赋。
不要再去学化妆了。
就是我没有意识知道。
自己能干什么？
能去多少次
以及把这个店的口碑。
它经营连份
是不是那种
职业必电人的模式。
摸摸清楚之后
就是想明白之后
再去消费
那就避免
成为韭菜的概率
然后拉低这个风险。
我们活在世界上
就是有很多风险的。
好了
我们今天先聊到这里。
大家应该很有共鸣吧？
我觉得讲到这里
所有的人都办过
一张最冤枉的会员卡吧？
来留言告诉我们
对
我觉得一个是留言告诉我们。
你们办过的最冤的卡。
还有就是你们有没有。
就是比较正能量的。
维权成功的经历
分享一下
其实我维权之后
我发现维权也没有那么难。
像我现在那些
学了位决的卡
我觉得我也可以尝试。
打12315问一下。
这个怎么弄
因为那些不合理的退换。
条款其实都是
应该改变的
好了 那今天
就聊到这里
拜拜
够了